I turn next to how we protect Public
Services through a challenging period
cross country has at its heart a strong
NHS and world-class education
we know that a strong economy depends on
strong public services so we will
protect them as much as we can as we
deliver our plan for stability and
growth
we do have to take difficult decisions
on public finances
so we're going to grow public spending
but we're going to grow it more slowly
than the growth in the economy
for the remaining two years of the
spending review we'll protect the
increases in departmental budgets we've
already set out in cash terms and then
grow resource spending at one percent a
year in real terms in the three years
that follow
although departments will have to make
efficiencies to deal with inflationary
pressures in the next two years
this decision means overall spending in
public services will continue to rise in
real terms for the next five years
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
before I turn to our plan for schools in
the NHS I start with two other areas of
spending
the department for work and pensions has
a critical role in supporting people
into work and I am proud to live in a
country with one of the most
comprehensive safety nets anywhere in
the world
but I am also concerned that we've seen
a sharp increase in economically
inactive working age adults of around
630
000 people since the start of the
pandemic employment levels have yet to
return to pre-pandemic levels which is
bad for businesses who cannot fill
vacancies and bad for people missing out
on the opportunity to do well for
themselves and their families so the
prime ministers asked the work and
pension secretary to do a thorough
review of issues holding back Workforce
participation to conclude early in the
New Year
alongside this I am also committed to
helping people already in work to raise
their incomes progress in work and
become financially independent so we
will ask over 600 000 more people on
Universal Credit to meet with a work
coach so that they can get the support
they need to increase their hours for
earnings
I've also decided to move back the
managed transition of people from
employment and support allowance onto
Universal credits of 2028 and we'll
invest an extra 280 million pounds in
DWP to crack down on benefit fraud and
error over the next two years and the
government's review of the state pension
age will also be published in early
2023.